welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode seven
which spoiler warning confirms agnes as
the witch agatha harkness
in a basement dungeon that i wish this
blue dungeon was give me a baphomet yak
head any day of the week and i'll yack
your ear off about it look there is so
much hidden in this episode so it's time
for another shot by
shot breakdown of everything you missed
to try to make sense of this and scare
you just a little bit let's get started
okay you may have noticed how each
episode the way wanda says previously on
wandavision gets progressively less and
less cheerful
previously on one division previously on
one division
previously on one division previously on
one division
previously on one division previously on
one division
reflecting her worsening mental state as
this fourth wall illusion collapses
around her
the jig is up folks the fourth wall is
broken and now agatha takes control
reframing this hex as her own show
agatha all along wanda's cover has a
pattern that's you guessed it hexagonal
so is vision's pillowcase but notice
he's not there
wanda's pillowcase ain't hexagonal maybe
reflecting that she is not really part
of this hex but
in her shame she chooses to blanket
herself in the hex to
try to escape her reality the boys weave
remotes glitch back into gamecube
controllers and then two atari joysticks
and then uno cards now uno was the game
played by
a young monica rambo with her scroll
friend in captain marvel a relationship
i believe we might be revisiting now
listen to the radio as wanda makes
[Music]
cereal
radio station wnda for wunder
also notice the dj calls the children of
westview little ghosts
maybe another clue pointing to the
theory i pitched last week that the
children who just showed up in west view
could be the souls of dead
children maybe the children who agatha
killed over the years
or one of those kids could be reflected
on this milk carton as a glitch it's now
showing a missing child photo now this
is after the milk just
worked from almond milk to vitamin d
milk in other words something vegan
to the milk with the most fat in it i'm
not saying they're eating babies oh yeah
i kind of
am because clearly this hex is for the
children for agatha to consume their
life force
actually did bite a kid once now one day
cereal has a circus theme with a clown
on it and a circus tint
maze on the back which is just like the
circus theme wanda's
expansion turned the sword camp into
similarly vision and darcy kind of get
lost in a maze
trying to get away from this circus back
to the heart of westview now these
opening credits are a fusion of three
modern sitcoms the piano music based on
the office
[Music]
the rapidly shifting titles based on the
happy endings intro happy endings was a
show produced by the russo brothers
before they moved on to marvel and then
this final title white and red on black
is based on the modern family logo and
all these home confession cams handheld
camera movement all based on the modern
family cinematography as well
well then these flashing titles are a
bunch of fun details the license plate
number
is 12 28 22 a nod to the birth date of
the late great stanley december 28 1922
another title says sorry where wanda as
in
wanda being synonymous for the word
closed the way she has closed herself
off from the outside world there's
another one and straight up kidnapper
letters i know what you are doing wanda
very i know you did last summer i like
the idea that this could be coming from
agatha
shaming wanda into closing herself off
leaving her kids vulnerable for
nom nom nom now another title shows us
some fridge magnets with b
and s visible in frame as in this
westview sitcom is
[ __ ] and then from hayward's new
sword camp the hex has
expanded so you can see its top edges
are also angled
not unlike folks a circus tent like the
circus of sword agents are now trapped
in now this
is a 3d hexagonal prism like
every angle you look at it there's a
hexagon which
shouldn't be possible like think about
how do you link a bunch of planar
hexagons in a way that they all fit
neatly together so this is a
theoretical shape like a tesseract which
in physics is actually a fourth
dimensional hypercube that's really only
capable of being seen by human eyes
as a 3d cube as this 4th dimensional
prism passes through
our 3d dimension i bring all this up
because this hyper hex
could be a similarly trans-dimensional
phenomenon
a hex from a dimension beyond our
perception that passes through
our 3d dimension and then warps the
nature of the system within it and i
lost you look
if you really want to get creeped out
check out this agent when hayward plants
do will probably nuke a new jersey town
yeah i feel very lucky what's happening
with the broadcast
what the hell is that movement it kind
of looks reversed
or scroll versed now over in the circus
agent monty is now the strong man darcy
is an escape artist you'll know some of
the employees wear jumpsuits with a
circusy version of the sword crest
later there's a booth for full the
guesser which i feel like is what this
show is trying to do to us
back home the weather shows sunny
weather with a chance of clouds
later when garcia drives she comments
how it never rains in westview yet it
does
on them and this is right after the
nexus commercial in which
dark rain clouds form billy asks about
uncle p
and wanda says don't believe anything
that man said he is not
your uncle who is he
uh and notice how wanda threateningly
points the remote at these boys
they look shaken as if mommy might
change them the way their game
controllers were just warped and then
agnes arrives and she's wearing purple
which is the color of agatha harkness we
actually see agatha harkness's ornate
purple dress in boots for a brief second
at the end of the episode
but she has been rocking agatha's brooch
the whole time the whole time
and we've seen all the clues up into
this point agnes is an amalgamation of
agatha harkness pretty much every word
of her mouth has been suspect the
devil's in the details bev
that's not the only place he is so
agatha of course is the witch who often
accompanies wanda in the comics now
she's not always
evil most of the time she's kind of
neutral or actually kind of a good guy
but in the west coast avengers run that
wanda vision seems partly based on
agatha gaslights wanda into thinking she
has kids who are
actually pieces of mephisto's soul as
pietro called them last episode
unleash hell demon spawn demon spawn
now here agnes says i think i got there
in the nick of time
because she was one split end away from
cutting her own bangs
nick of time and her rabbit is in your
scratchy which some think could be a nod
to agatha son
nicholas scratch and cutting her own
bangs
agnes might have been afraid wanda is
about to cut aka
erase her bangs these things she got by
you know banging am i reaching shut up
and agnes says
i do have a suspicious mole on my back
that i just
can't see if uh
boundaries i get it say no more
moles of course are associated with
witches people thought it was a mark of
the devil but notice how the camera cuts
away right as agnes
lifts her top but look at wanda's face
and tommy's face they're not just
weirded out by agnes doing this they are
disgusted by whatever it is they see
i'm assuming there's some hideous
pestering mole under there and wanda
says
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine she has now become mrs hart
stop it stop
it both of them channeling that scene
and get out
stomping no no no no no no no no no
stop it and kind of me when joker says
we live in a society
no no no no no no and by the way if you
want to support my insanity you can
check out all of our great merch options
at new rockstarsmerch.com this is our
latest obsession shirt and unusual
couple it's a way to support the channel
directly and get a great shirt okay so
jimmy receives darcy's cataract email
and if you look at his screen darcy ends
this email with
this is a decoy communique he sent to
vision's office so that answers who sent
vision that email in episode five
it was a ploy by hayward to shake vision
out of the trance to try to get him to
leave westview so that hayward could
retrieve his sentient weapon
monica meets up with this sword unit led
by major goodner
my mother would appreciate your loyalty
she's not the only one we're loyal to
captain
so is goodner the big mystery engineer
the past two episodes were setting up to
be like a big deal that everyone thought
was gonna be reed richards
well let's think about this goodner
likely worked for sword space program
i'm actually assuming these are the
astronauts who didn't report back to
hayward but instead of them just not
having the nerve maybe they just thought
he was a dick
undoing maria rambo's legacy and i have
a suspicion that this unit
is a sword division of scrolls maybe the
unit fury is attached to on that space
station
goodner could be a grown-up version of
taylor's daughter
monica's uno playing pal staring clear
of hayward because
unlike maria and monica he views aliens
as threats
and they're not yet revealing themselves
to jimmy wu because he brainstormed
scrolls as possible perpetrators of all
this but they could totally trust him
just look at that smile he walked up
with he probably begged to stop and get
him coffee he's the
best now the tag number 9219r are
probably for rover 9219 could be a nod
to the year 1992 which would have been
in the window of time
sorin her daughter and the other
squirrels were hidden in earth's orbit
that would be 1989 to 1995 maybe
something big happened in 1992 maybe
1992 was the first year they built this
river darcy tells vision
fine i'll go out with you but i'm
ordering the lobster now remember
lobster was on the menu back in the
first episode so i like this little
thing of darcy being kind of a stan
because even though she's in the heck
she might subconsciously still be
shipping herself with her sitcom dream
boo
now this hula girl could be a nod to the
one in agents of shield remember skye
had one of these in those framework
episodes that was the event where
coulson ranted about the hydra soap that
we've talked about before as the house
glitches the stork returns and then
moana says this to the confession cam
i can't fix it do you think maybe this
is what you deserve
what you're not supposed to talk huh now
at first this
reminded me of the moment in the office
where a crew member appears on screen
for the first time and everyone's like
what the [ __ ] they're actually
committing to this format modern family
just pretended like there's no reason
for a documentary which kind of made it
creepy why camera crew would be filming
claire
and phil hooking up in weird
role-playing scenarios
now this is my favorite detail episode
later the agatha all along sequence
revealed agatha to be the one behind the
camera agatha probably the director of
this show
but this male voice here is actually
katherine han's voice
pitch shifted downward do you think
maybe this is what you deserve
do you think maybe this is what you
deserve now next this commercial for
nexus anti-depressant and holy [ __ ] my
theory was right
roll that clip john do not be surprised
if this next commercial
in the modern family era is a
stereotypical pharmaceutical ad
medication for anxiety depression folks
this doesn't always happen
and if mephisto ain't in this show this
might be the only vindication i get
anyway nexus the reality of your choice
the world revolving around you yeah
these are all references to wanda
maximoff being a
nexus being in marvel lore an individual
who exists separate from
any one reality or timeline this is how
wanda was able to flip realities in
house of m
and this tells us that this series is
probably setting up the marvel
multiverse
actually you can see this bottle behind
ithmar there reads multi probably from
multivitamin but the word multi's there
so this is a big deal even if evan
peters pietro is not quicksilver from
the fox sexman universe
clearly with this hex expanding and
expanding that could be one way reality
is rewritten in a house of m way to
create the multiverse a crisis that
they'll have to deal with in loki and
spider-man 3 and multiverse madness
bear in mind characters like jean grey
and kang the conqueror are also
technically nexus beans so i think we'll
get a much clearer definition of what
exactly this means with the tva and loki
look at that word nexopromicide
that suffix side means something that
kills my spermicide
so this is 10.3 percent nexus promoting
killing as in wanda is using her nexus
status to reset reality
to kill off 10.3 percent of people
no more mutants or you could read this
as an active ingredient that kills off
or reduces by 10.3 percent one's
affinity to use the nexus
to chaotically rewrite reality giving
wanda greater control over what would
normally be super chaotic i love the way
this commercial shot this woman lays
down in bed but then they rebuild the
set so that the bed is
on a wall that she steps away from so
her reality was literally
turned on its axis so that she can
actively step
forward from that depression sinkhole on
a level plane
in the corner of the screen it reads see
our ad in the westview gazette a nod of
the newspaper that keeps showing up with
ads for appliances reflecting vision as
an appliance and hayward's eyes and the
voiceover also says ask your doctor
which could be a nod to dr strange being
the doc who helps break wanda's
addiction to this reality warping in
multiverse of madness
and it ends with this woman stepping to
the right into this red glow
as if to say the way forward little lady
is to take this nexus med become queen
of your own reality warp
into a red tinted hex yes i know while
i'm going through these easter eggs and
theories you gotta look at this dumb
face with this dumb beard on it but that
doesn't make me a neck beard i like to
clean it up around the edges to that i
have to do a bit of shaving my favorite
part of that is how smooth my skin feels
afterwards well thanks to our sponsor
harry's i am feeling smoother than ever
so harry's is a personal care brand that
has reinvented the way you
shave helping you to shave in a premium
hassle-free way
their german manufactured blades are
sharper than ever
and they're still the same low price of
only two dollars each they have this
high quality weighted handle with a
texturized rubber grip and
a five blade razor cartridge that feels
really great in your hand and does an
incredible job i also love their shaving
gel which is great for
sensitive skin okay so i'm really just
like going down and it's like
it smells really good and
the fine blade it's just super smooth
it's getting that nice smooth
feel to it and like it's so like nice
and creamy it smells really good too
and by getting harry's you can help
harry support great causes as they give
one percent of their global sales to
nonprofit organizations that provide
mental health care to men
veterans and lgbtq plus youths in need
redeem your trial set for just
three dollars when you go to harrys.com
new rockstars
you'll get a five blade razor weighted
handle travel cover and their foaming
shave gel
it's an incredibly great deal but act
fast while supplies last
and then billy tells agnes you're quiet
agnes
on the inside a signal that billy as a
telepath death ended by all the noise in
westview is unable to read agatha's
thoughts
nor the thoughts of the quiet senor
scratchy actually notice when called out
agatha freezes
her hand just over the rabbit almost as
if ready to
activate him into a new form and agnes
mentions ralph
ralph says i sugarcoat things but you
try telling a ten-year-old that his
mother is cuckoo for cocoa puffs
now on the table before her are these
violet flowers with
leafy stems these look like the flowers
that are all over her yard the leafs
look like what
billy was just feeding to the rabbit or
it could have been spinach or it could
have been these leaves
my theory is that this plant is the
wundigor everbloom
the plant that grows in agatha
harkness's yard in the comics that
once eaten gives one visions of what
life could be via
feelings of pain in the tom king vision
comics sparky the dog had eaten this
plant discovered after virginia beated
him to death
and i believe agatha killed sparky for
digging up this plant
in her yard and that she has been
drugging wanda with this plant
all along all along think about it the
plant that she first brought her in
episode one a plant tied with a purple
ribbon
the dinner in episode one her booze in
episode two the lavender spray in
episode five
and now in a medicinal form notice that
wanda pops
pills and what does agnes do for when
she arrives
brews her tea i'm assuming some herbal
tea
herb hold on herb she even makes an herb
out of herb and why is she doing this
well the drugging keeps wanda in the
fantasy
so that agatha can consume the life
force of her children
now did agnes actually gobble up these
kids like the witch and the hansel and
gretel story no no they're probably
locked up somewhere
or part of some kind of ritual somewhere
deep in that dungeon as they are being
what reassumed in mephisto maybe drained
of their energy but like house of them i
think this is all gonna end with wanda
not being able to hold on to these kids
now monica activates a spectrometer in
the rover cockpit
this measures radiation and it's the
same device bruce banner used to track
the tesseract in the avengers put the
spectrometers on the roof and calibrate
them for gamma rays
and monica pushes herself through
[Music]
this audio is from the captain marvel
film we actually heard this softly as
monika unblipped back in episode four
now on captain marvel this is the scene
where carol and maria and fury
were about to launch i can't leave
monica mom
it's okay i gotta stay with grandma and
paw paw there's no way i'm going baby
it's too dangerous
maybe i could fly up and meet you
halfway oh only if you learn to glow
like your auntie carol but i love
the visuals of this monica's face
stretches from itself like in the movie
contact when jodie foster has an
interdimensional travel and her face is
here but it's also here
scott derrickson actually said this
visual inspired doctor strange's trip
through the multiverse and i bring it up
because that is essentially what is
happening here
monica splits into a spectrum of her
various roles in her life the moment she
unblipped looking for her mother in the
hospital
then an astronaut then a government
agent and then geraldine
think about it this is kind of the order
of her life priorities as she's
progressing forward
daughter first and then starbound
explorer and then
country serving agent and then maximum
selflessness
even in defiance of her own country a
sacrificial empath
just trying to talk an avenger off a
ledge but then monica pulls
all of herselves into one and then
sticks to superhero landing she actually
does one later this episode too
her eyes are now glowing blue and she
sees the westview anomaly in its true
irradiated state kinda like neo see in
the matrix
folks we just saw monica rambo become
photon
an avenger with powers similar to
captain marvel it's fitting that her
transformation matches how carol went
binary how
by sinking all of her past selves all of
her past stumbles and all of her past
arising but i gotta say this one looks
way cooler and notice how her clothes
underneath match the color scheme and
clothes a photon in the comics
dennis the mailman now works for
delivery service presto with a
rabbit logo on his hat there is a pixar
short titled presto about a rabbit
feuding with his magician on stage
during a show
similar to the way senor scratchy ran
amok during vision's magic show
something ag that just revealed was her
doing so i believe senior scratchy
is either agatha's son nicholas scratch
and that might be who evan peters pietro
is think about it rabbits are quick
little speedsters the other option
is senior scratchy could be old scratch
agatha's husband
ralph but i'm not gonna go as far to say
that is the mailman but the fact that he
is wearing this rabbit logo means that
he is like all these things are
under axis control i'm wondering what is
in those brad g lay packages though
maybe some supplies to help agatha
maintain this drugging
now agnes breaks up the heartbelt moment
between monica and wanda
wanda young lady i think you overstayed
you're welcome
run along dear young lady dear it's like
little old lady colloquialisms hey
dearly why don't you take a weathers i'm
missing ncis
now in agnes home there are hexagon
patterns on the cups
and then yo gabba gabba on the tv listen
to them they're saying
jump jump jump almost as if inviting
wanda to take the plunge into the
basement now some say you can see the
chair
move on its own behind wanda as she
turns to look at senor scratchy but this
is really a trick of the eye folks see
the camera starts in a pan
and then curves around wanda's face
right as she turns her head so you don't
really notice the curve as much
and doing so it makes that chair behind
her look like it's just suddenly
scooting itself behind the wall but it's
just the way the camera's pointed but
then
wanda sees this cicada now cicadas are
said to symbolize
immortality these things sleep for like
17 years before they hatch there could
be a parallel here with agatha
who might stay dormant for years and
years and then re-emerge to make her
move
personally i can't help but see this as
a nod to the silence of the lambs the
moment chloe starling sees the moth in
the home of buffalo bill and that's how
she realizes she is in the home of the
killer they've been looking for
a killer who is hiding horrors in the
basement and down there wanda finds this
dungeon my heart's desire now first
notice how the aspect ratio widens
telling us that wanda has
left the hex temporarily this dungeon is
in the real world now in this place
folks an
animal head across the way this is
either a goat a
ram i'm thinking maybe a yak something
baphomet like
demonic faces are carved into the
pillars above
hexagons with golden symbols etched in
you can see more animal bones in a red
lit cabinet
a winged creature in another corner and
of course the big one
this glowing book most likely the dark
hold
the ancient marvel book of the dead
created by chathan
the demon who in the comics cursed wanda
maximoff with her powers as a baby
the darkhold appeared in agents of
shield it had a different cover agents
of shield unfortunately is not really
considered canon by kevin feige so this
is probably just gonna be a new version
of the dark hold this symbol on it looks
interesting it's like two keys joining
together to open a central lock
now i've speculated this book could be
from the camera tag library which would
root wanda's sorcery in doctor strange's
eldritch magic which could explain its
hexagonal geometric shape like many of
the sorcerer's spells take these
interesting angular geometric shapes now
some are saying this could be the
necronomicon which was derived from the
darkhold i think it's more likely to
just be the darkhold and it's gonna be
used to justify all the supernatural
elements in the mcu
like blade but here this is likely the
source of the hex that this witch is
putting over wanda because
folks this is a satanic temple and the
witch who occupies it reveals herself
the name's agatha harkness
lovely to finally meet you dear and then
an amazing revised intro sequence
revealing it was
agatha all along notice how agatha
starts by floating to the ground to help
this domestic family
like mary poppins who is a witch don't
forget that
then the lyrics say she pulled every
evil string
but it's interesting it doesn't say
anything about her creating this x it
just makes her sound like she's meddling
in the hex but all this includes senior
scratchy
herb pietro killing sparky
she lied to vision and it looks like it
was to get him to leave and get him out
of the picture so that
she and pietro could move in on those
kids this whole sequence the music
sounds like it's the monster's theme but
notice the female vocals here actually
done by catherine hahn herself
[Applause]
[Music]
now notice how agatha picnicked as
pietro arrived perhaps that creepy
appendage we saw in the mirror was her
magic pulling him into the house now
piatro also appears in the post-credits
scene of this episode
surprising monica when she snoops into
the basement snooper's gonna snoop
oh you'll notice monica's eyes glow
purple but i don't think this means
agatha's magic has hold of her
because she still reacts cognitively to
pietro she's not in a trance yet
i just think as photon her eyes
illuminate to reveal energy that
wouldn't normally be visible to the
naked eye like how they glowed blue
earlier but interesting here notice
agnes's car has a connecticut license
plate not a new jersey one agnes did
mention how her and ralph's anniversary
was june 2nd the day the salem witch
trials began in 1692. salem is in
massachusetts but
at that time witch trials and executions
were happening all over new england
including connecticut but as
monica peeks into the door look at the
window to the right a
shadow moves independent of monica's
reflection this is something else inside
i'm thinking this could be senor
scratchy turned into pietro and
presto darted over to monica to catch
her look folks i'm not going to try to
fool you agatha is clearly the villain
of the show
west view is her operation but she's got
associations with witchcraft with dark
magic
and there's still a very good chance she
has a silent partner that we haven't met
yet and all signs are pointing to
mephisto
not just the devil in the details not
just demon spawn a paul bettany
interview was released this week
suggesting there is still an
unseen major cameo popping up there is
one
character that has not been revealed and
it is
very exciting as an actor that i've
longed to work with
all of my life and in the same interview
paul bettany seemed
really coy about mephisto in particular
i can't speak to
right now because i'm worried about
getting fired so as great as this agatha
reveal is
i think most of us did see it coming so
there is probably one deeper mystery
left in the shadows
the darkest is yet to come hey by the
way if you want to win a free ps5
our merch partners epic hero are doing a
giveaway all you got to do subscribe to
the channel epic hero labs and then head
over to
heroshop.com giveaway for more ways to
enter you can continue this nerdy
conversation on new rockstar's official
discord server by becoming a patron at
patreon.com
new rockstars follow me at eavos follow
new rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
all your wanted vision questions
thank you for watching and uh singing
along with me who gets his theories 10.3
percent right it was eric vos
all along
[Music]
you